they worked well there's a there's a
good I think a good example in South
Africa there are many other truth
Commission's out there South Africa's
the most famous in which they seem to
have worked pretty well South Africa is
an amazing story of a country that
completely transformed itself in a
non-violent way into you know again not
a perfect society there's a lot of
bitterness very understandable but the
truth and reconciliation process seems
to have been fairly widely accepted it
has a certain advantage over trials
which is you know one other alternative
to have a kind of trial and the war
crimes trials or other trials of that
type are very costly you can only kind
of try a few people and and so the
appeal of truth and reconciliation is
that it's less legalistic you can reach
out to more p.m. in II many differences
but it allows you to to achieve
reconciliation rather than simply a
judgement so so that said I think it has
it has some real advantages but it's not
it certainly has not been used
everywhere right and so Saddam Hussein
was tried by a national court the
International Criminal Court obviously
takes a criminal justice model rather
than the TRC had an amnesty process so
if you confessed and you confessed fully
and were perceived to have confessed
fully you could be granted amnesty that
was controversial but that was an
essential part of the vision the
International Criminal Court doesn't do
that that's a very different model so so
I think it really depends on on many
different factors and I think we're
really in a learning process right now
over the last 25 years we've been
experimenting with all of these
different models national courts
international courts some kind of a
hybrid international national chief
commissions straight up amnesties right
some people say we should just grant an
amnesty and you know like the many of
the sub-saharan African dictators they
retire to the South of France